I reckon I'm gonna get that lease option
agreement I really have a good feeling
time in you guys whatever I'll watch the
time is now 5 to 5 on the 1st of April
and I'm gonna refresh the page and see
what's going on with my other advert and
I'm really hoping I'm feeling a little
bit nervous right now because I need
some houses it's saying in review okay
the good news is I've got a whole batch
more investors I might go 40 investors
which is fantastic but the motivated
sellers one here one active bad oh I
don't know if it's active or not what
does learning mean normally it's either
failed or it's active or it's pending
but it's shown up is learning which I
don't understand I don't know that means
I need some houses man because I'm
getting all these these investors but
I've got another thing to send to them
because I haven't got any properties and
if I don't because I'd doesn't go live
Syrian I'm gonna need to we strategize
so it's now the 2nd of April I've got
some pretty bad news the investor list
is going crazy I've now had 79 PP
applications for properties it's costing
me 23 pence per lead so my total spend
has been 17 pound 82 so that's great and
those guys want some deals
however the motivated sellers add to
actually get deals and to get houses is
still in learning mode which I don't
understand it's in learning mode but it
is seeming to be somewhat active because
I've had one motivated seller but the
details in which is great and problem is
to get that it's cost me 18 pound 50 so
18 pound 50 just to get one lead is is
is abysmal so what I'm thinking what I
think I'm gonna do is I'm gonna jump on
I'm gonna change the ad I'm gonna I'm
gonna do a new ad for motivated sellers
which hopefully will get approved fast
and we'll get a much better return and
I'm gonna do that alongside contacting
people on gumtree I'm open went on spare
room I want to be sending texts emails
and today's I just need to go crazy
today I'm trying to get some actual
deals sewn on because if the motivated
sellers out there have gone as well if
the investors ad and it was I was just
fooling with deals it would just be a
case of ringing up the motivated sellers
really piece of together all through
Facebook Ads
but it's obviously not that simple so
time to get to work okay let's do this
so we've got the ABS I'm waiting for
that to become actual not learning and
actually get some people because I don't
we've got one lead to go out and he
hasn't even left his phone number so I'm
gonna go chew gum tree and let's see
what we can find
now the crazy thing is as well if you go
on Rightmove right now there's people
still put in their houses on the market
which again is crazy so let's see what
we can find if I type in let's say
stoke-on-trent I am wise stoke-on-trent
no reason just because it's it's kind of
mid is the Midlands the mid north
let's see what properties are coming on
added to site in the last three days
surely not surely no one is putting
their house on the market now I don't
really care too much about the property
we're just going to be seeing what we
can get so the last three days there's
been 241 properties listed in the last
three days just is absolutely crazy not
HMO HMO investment opportunity I guess
people are scared right now in Salford
that's a good property what would happen
if I run the estate agent I don't even
know I don't know ever they'd answer I
mean the night it'd be as easy as I can
find deals on Rightmove right now four
six eight I'm gonna bring the agent and
just see what the crack is and what on
earth is going on
if call may be recorded for quality and
training purposes this call may also be
recorded for training purposes
so there's bought for 60 grand very
cheap so they're not gonna have a big
mortgage on it is now the time to be
actually investing in property so what's
the point
putting your house on the market right
now an estate agent if the estate agents
are now closed that is just crazy
so this person wants to sell but the
property came on on the market on the
31st of March to be sold of no chain
they're really keen to get rid of it
EPC looks high though hmm okay I mean
listen if you know what's what so how
much is that house worth well let's find
out how much it might be worth it's fine
the address I'm gonna get the address
I'll do a quick check to see if the
property is overpriced
it might be worth 180 200 grand like
that could be within seconds that could
be the deal that I'm looking for
I don't know but there's stuff to get my
teeth into that's for sure I should have
done this earlier
that's the postcode I know the property
sold in 2005 for 60 grand so let's see
2005 60 grand let me see if I get the
full address 2005 60 grand 2 grand 2005
that's the one so that's number one
number one and the postcode does the
postcode match up m6 yes it does
brilliant so that will be the address of
the house so now we've got the address
of the house we can see its whole
history
Land Registry we can start doing some
due diligence some research on the house
I mean I might have to I could send a
letter I guess in the letter to the
house the only problem is means that is
the landlord is a lot unlikely to be at
the property with it being H amount
let's see how much the house is worth
according to Maus price on from 116 it
just came on they'll take an offer there
they'll take a hit on that but it might
already be cheap so you say it's only
worth 120 but that says a two-bed house
from to that
they've obviously done a lot to the
property they've changed it up so that's
probably probably not right it's not
taking into account the fact that it's a
HMO okay that's my first that's my firs
lead so I'm just gonna need to just keep
doing this until we can find some juice
until we can find some juicy leads maybe
start sending some letters let's see
what we can we keep we I'm gonna I'm
gonna stick to right mood for a little
bit now if Maus price was really excited
about the price and they were selling it
really cheap then I'd be excited but I
don't I don't get a feeling that they
are something it really cheap let's see
what else he's selling in the area I'm
sure if I could package something up
good I'm sure my new 83 or whatever it
is investors would be interested see
these are two bad in there like 120 once
you find these of sold sold sold sold
120 so my one was eight a four-bed and
it's a HMO 125 so it probably is on
other others this is it one six days but
this one's too bad 200 for a five but it
probably is on a fair price okay gum
chewer okay so it's in Burnley it's four
beds what's the rent rental income
seventeen thousand six hundred eighty
that sounds pretty good that sounds
pretty good okay and this just came on
twelve minutes ago so if I can get a
deal on this I mean it might be
something to send out to my guys even if
the finder's fee is only small because
seventeen thousand six eighty divided by
12 that's 1407
three pounds per month that's a that
that's a really good yield the question
is can I get it below market value
because this is gonna need to be bought
by cash buy I would imagine because of
how crazy to finance lenders have been
and am I going to be talking to a source
or already I don't want to be getting
into a daisy-chain of deal sources I
want to be talking to the landlord
direct or an agent hi there my name is
Samuel I'm just ringing about a property
hm a property that you just posted on
gumtree I think you just posted like 12
minutes ago all right so that's cool so
they're going to send me over see if I
can say look man you bet I hate to know
that you sell in yes it's renting out
right now for seventeen thousand six
eighty but any minute your tenants could
stop paying you can't evict them and
lenders aren't lending self well I want
a deal I found that on gumtree man I
want a deal if I can get a deal where I
can provide that below market value and
and they and the return on investments
really good as well I've got something
like an email out you know I need yeah
listen I mean I'm quite experienced
property investor I've never bought
houses in a lockdown crisis like this
before so I don't know exactly the
protocol my my thinking on this and I'll
be guided somewhat by you is that as
long as I can get everything like I
don't know if surveyors ever even still
go into properties I don't know but
I don't know if if surveyors are still
even going out into properties I know
that solicitors are working but I mean
I'm just thinking if I can get like a
video tour pictures for all plans as
much information and then if and then
I'll just have to buy it subject to a
survey and send a surveyor out that's
probably what I was thinking but I don't
know thanks so much bye hmm so what
she's saying is people are buying
properties subject to surveys and then
whenever the value was and servos go out
it's just a question of who can have the
best negotiation skills to get the
survey is to go out quickly they are
still going out there only wanting to go
to publish they're committed to but we
can get around that yeah he's a property
salsa that's what I'm doing so it's a
bet so I think he's playing then I'll
get some information here yeah okay well
basically my situation is I'm a property
investor so at the moment with all
what's going on
everyone's worried because they can't
view properties now when I bought houses
to be honest I don't usually view them
anyway
most of my portfolio I've just have
surveys on them and I'm not physically
used them before I bought them so I'm
kind of just thinking it could
potentially be an opportunity for me to
to get some really good deals so if
there's if there's people selling I mean
I can potentially buy cash and I've got
I've got a portfolio of HMOs already so
how does it work then with you stuff so
if you
if you're well if you're like a sorcerer
do you charge of faith and then you say
BMV properties do you know it I was just
saying you talking about below market
value deals and you saw some properties
and stuff so do you do you kind of
negotiate the prices already kind of
yeah and then do you charge a fee to the
investor or how does it how many worker
from from from well I'm okay so if I was
if I was doing it doing it cashed it
because I imagine I mean what would
because this is not the normal normally
because I've been speaking some agents
and it's just a case of you know there's
there's a property there's a price
whereas with you guys because you're
kind of more hands-on with the whole
experience of the whole package is just
a little bit different it's just no bit
different so I'm just trying to get my
head around there so so basically what
if I was to buy a property off of you
for 40,000 pounds cash you would then
oversee the refurb process and then and
everything and it would ultimately be a
luxury for bad multi that property which
is which is great by Wow so they are
doing viewings and social distancing in
the viewings that's crazy join this
lockdown they're still just going at it
that's insane I don't think I would
attempt to do that they're not an estate
agent they're an agent but there
the deal forces so they deal packages
and their fees are like 12 grand so
there's no way that I could secure a
deal through them and then pass it on to
my investor list because they've already
put their feet on it so probably not
going to work it was interesting
interesting what you said about the fact
that there's still mortgage lenders that
are lending but some of them are just
being a little bit more resistant I'm
not sure I think he's probably just
caught off guard a little bit with the
whole Cove at 19 and they're still
figuring out exactly what to do I think
everybody is including me so miss your
advice
I think cheap HMOs that you can buy cash
are going to be what people are really
really excited about right now but all
of these properties are going to be good
luxury villa in Thailand always tempting
hundred grand
I want liming in Thailand right now
let's see what else we can find
five bed house 325 see though these
private sale need quick quick private
sound needed 490 grands SAR by auction
there's a lot I think these look like
that HMO company again who are you know
I'd probably a very very good company
but just not quite what we're needing to
do right now okay look sure we hate your
mo that's impressed them six bit hmm
Wolverhampton but that's expensive six
beds I guess it's all right but I mean
how much would they drop by let's see if
this is with this is with property
investor app see I don't want to be
talking to an investor app I just want
me talking to a motivated seller not
some in-between person Lee Road I know
Lee Road I know it really well finder's
fee five thousand-pound see these guys
are all charge of finders fees that's
what I want to be doing I don't want to
be talking to someone who's already put
in a fee on it that's the difficulty
here but the fact that other people are
doing it I wonder if they're actually
selling properties
a lot of these are in a negotiated deal
so look at this 35 percent below market
value refurbishment opportunity they say
it's 35 percent below market value but I
don't believe that often I often think
that when people say this that they say
that the market value isn't a new market
value once it's done up now maybe I'm
being a little bit cynical the thing is
I don't know what my investors want
right now so I could be negotiating for
properties and I could be and I could be
I could be finding stuff in the wrong
areas that my guys aren't interested in
so I think what actually I'm gonna do
let me send an email to my guys and ask
them what they're looking for I've now
got 89 people how much am i how much how
much have I spent to get that let's see
I've spent 20 pounds 75 that is not a
lot of money so I spent 20 quid and I've
got 89 investors I'm gonna email these
investors and I want to say to them hey
what are you looking for so let's get
this let's get this up download hey
there's a massive thank you for joining
my mailing list I've got loads of really
exciting property investment
opportunities coming up over the next
day or two so stay tuned keep your ears
peeled keep checking your email list now
listen if you're looking for something
specific I want to know exactly what
you're looking for where are you looking
what kind of properties are the kind of
deals where you would buy right now
today let me know I'm gonna be on the
phone negotiating working hard using my
ten years property experience to work on
your behalf
finding deals ping me an email back let
me know exactly what you're looking for
and what you would buy if it was handing
to you on a plate today let me know so
I'm gonna send that over to my guys now
and hopefully they'll start telling me
what they're looking for which is gonna
keep me on track to make sure that I'm
looking for the right kind of deals
because if they all say oh I'm looking
for HMOs great if they all say I'm
looking for apartments if they say I'm
looking for things in London I don't
know what they're looking for so that'll
be a really good we call this market
research okay so that video that I just
did is now loading onto YouTube should
be on YouTube in 60
second 15 seconds 14 seconds and once
it's live I'm gonna email that's all my
investors of a little note a little
cover note and you know see what they're
looking for but to be honest if it deals
really good
I mean if it's heavily below market
value if it's a high return on
investment then there'll be someone that
would want to buy anyway but good bit of
market research so now for data
protection I'm gonna email this to
myself
properties at Samuel Leeds and I'm going
to blind copy in everybody else boom so
now they won't see that email so now I
just need to write the message put the
video and then I can send that out
regards
Samuel EADS PS I made a little video for
you and then that video is going to
because I feel like sometimes when they
see you and they then they're more
likely to kind of get build trust it's a
36 second video which I'm going to send
to these guys right now
interesting Sam so now with no website
even with Facebook with no landing page
is no CRM system with absolutely nothing
I've literally spent 20 pounds got
ninety one property investors names and
email addresses emailed them all out
from my phone saying what are you
looking for they're gonna now be
emailing me about what they're looking
for is going to be an extra point of
contact which is also going to be
building trust because every time they
contact me they're going to be warmer to
buy whilst I'm looking for deals this is
happening
hello is that David hi David my name is
Samuel I'm just ringing about yesterday
[Music]
yeah no that makes sense
all right cool cool makes sense well
basically I'll just I'll just cut to the
chase I mean I'm a property investor so
[Music]
I'm looking to buy at the moment but I
am looking I mean I can put an offer on
the table for you and you can see how it
goes and wait to see if you get any
better offers but I am needing to this
is my business so I can buy quick I can
buy cash but it is it is discounted
especially with the times with covert 19
so it wouldn't be for it wouldn't be
full market value it would be well I'm
looking to pay about 80% of the market
value so 80% of the market value is what
I'm looking to pay so
yeah well I mean I know you've well I
mean I'm not doing a lot of research
because I wanted to speak to you first
before you know cuz for all I know I
could just spend half an hour doing
research and then call you in your cell
sorry it's just so you know so I've
nothing a lot of research or I looked on
mouse price and again by the way I mean
my business oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
yeah no that's totally fair enough yeah
well all I was looking at I'll do and
I'll just put it out there and it might
be that you have to just say look I'll
save your number and call you back if
things fall out of bed with the other
guy I mean there's another one on the
market very on the same street which to
be fair is a mid terrace but that's on
at 96 and it's not sold it's been on a
few months no I'm not suggesting that
yours is that's a like-for-like I'm just
saying that with it with in on the
street that's the only one that's that's
currently up for sale yeah yeah there's
also I often use Mouse price for
valuations and it's coming up on Mouse
price and I'm I'm sure it's it's it's
it's not this price and it's not correct
but I'm Mouse price valuations it's
coming up at 9999 thousand so I mean
[Music]
yeah yeah I'm sure I have I have no
doubt that your property is worth around
about 130,000 in in good times when when
mortgages
yeah yeah no I'm sure it's a nice yeah
no that's I have no doubt I think the
thing is in terms of the actual price
and the only reason I'd be you know
wouldn't quite be able to go up to 103
and again I'll just leave it with you
and you can just keep my number it's
just because the right now with how bad
with how bad things are with we've
covered 19 mortgages aren't lending so
which is going to absolutely crash the
market so if I was I'm just gonna come
I'm just I'm just saying it's put it
will probably be around about 95 but
that would be a quick cash no mess no
listen I get that that's lower and I get
that you can't accept that yeah yeah no
that's fair that's fair enough well
listen keep my number okay
[Music]
yeah fine
oh yes and over to me and I'll save you
number save mine and we'll keep in touch
if anything changes yeah to me and then
it just it just keeps it keeps it on the
table and I hope that you get the price
you want with the other guy but if not
come back and we can we can pick it up
cheers David do you have a great one
thanks for your time bye all right see
that that's how it can be you don't have
to be really cutthroat when you're
negotiating and really offensive you
just say look man I don't want to offend
you I'm a business man I've got to make
money on it is it or iPhone be from
direct so if he's property if the other
guys now pull out if they relying on a
mortgage or whatever and they pull out
and I can end up getting that 495 this
is just business I'm not trying to screw
them over I just want a good deal and I
want a good deal because I'm fighting to
get a good deal for my investors and I
want them to be so overwhelmed with how
good the deal is now cheaper I've got it
that they're happily paying me two three
four five thousand pounds because I've
had to have conversations like this
which most people won't have now I
actually think one hundred and three
thousand pounds for that house it's
probably a pretty good buy but I didn't
want to tell him that I said to him
listen dude call me back you didn't go
any lower and the reason I did that was
because he might go lower however I'm
gonna keep that reserved in my maybe bag
because I really think that could be
could be a good one no I'm thinking I'm
looking for deals and I've got some
interesting leads I've gone out but that
guy that I spoke to earlier who said his
house was worth 130 I reckon it's
probably worth about 125 because mouths
price has 120 super says 130 it's
probably about 125 he said except 103
cash offer
and I went wanted to go lower I wanted
to go in at life night high 90s and he
said no 103 I'm wondering whether I
should just email that out to my list as
in a bit of a taster and just say hey
you know I've got this deal it's not
done and dusted but it's worth 1 to 5
I've got it for 103 if you're interested
you have to sign an NDA and then I'll
give you all the details and if you want
to buy it
2 grand a fee might be worth an email if
I don't get anything else any other
deals by the end of the day I think I'll
email that out and just just see what
happens because I've got over 100
investors now I could literally I might
have what I need in front of me but I'm
gonna keep trying to get more deals but
that is a very possible one but right
now I'm really excited about the lease
option but I think I'll keep that myself
so another property also ever could
David now this property looks like it
needs a complete refurb so 45 if I
bought this for less than 40 there'd be
no stamp duty in fact there be no
statute you probably anyway to be fair
because it's in such bad condition
too bad it's currently this property is
currently getting fully decorated
once done up I will put new pictures of
the property okay so it's being dinner
that's good I can't see the address so
let's call David and see what we can do
it's in Hartlepool hi there is a David
hi David hi David my name is Samuel I'm
just phoning in response to your Gumtree
advert for the to bed terraced house in
Hartlepool yeah so basically I'm a
property investor and I just thought I'd
give you a call just to see if I get a
little bit more information about the
about the house so the pictures it looks
like it needs quite a lot of work but
you've said that you're currently
decorating yeah you do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah okay and what
what's your I mean why are you selling
it are you a you an investor or landlord
yourself or is it your at your home okay
David if you got me a texture with the
address all I'll crunch some numbers and
then or maybe just drop your text back
with some ideas or give you a call back
and see what I'm thinking
all right hey thanks so much for your
time I appreciate it
see you later bye the problems of him is
he's a developer he's not that motivated
by the sounds of it he didn't seem to be
freaking out about Corona he's just love
whatever but hey once he gives me the
address or about to value it and see
what we can do you should text me the
address
all right let's do
due diligence so he's asking for forty
five grand for the property let's see
how much is worth someone start by going
on mass price and mass price is saying
it's where these guys are just put in
their houses not too expensive man sieve
I said to him I'll give you 35 over the
phone cuz I just thought the asking
price is 45
therefore the value is 45 I could have
ended up being really screwed mass price
is awesome hello it's Samuel
it's a Nicola Nicola
I'm only phoned about the house that you
have got advertised on gumtree yes it is
still available yes all right cool so
basically I'm just gonna cut to the
chase if you've got a second yeah my
name is Samuel I'm a property investor
I've got I've got quite a lot of
properties that I rent out so I mean I
would I would be able to potentially buy
the property I can see I can see it
looks like a nice family family home but
it will be for rental purposes so I've
been renting it out now listen as a
property investor I can act fast I've
got cash but I am always looking for a
good deal so I typically buy about about
80% of the market value so I don't know
what your situation is but if I could
help and if you looking to sell
reasonably quickly then you know
potentially we could we can we could
work something out but that's kind of my
situation so how's it going your end I
know it's a crazy time to be alive right
now yeah
chili CeCe I'll get divorce the moon
there's no Rena
no check would be in the house at all so
just go straight
yeah I understand that I understand that
cuz so what's the mortgage outstanding
is it like about 115 no I I totally
understand that and I think I know the
area as well and I think you know I
think there's a lot of people in that
kind of situation so okay I mean have
you considered just renting you out and
sitting on it because if you've got if
you pass yeah what are the in body
monthly mortgage payments on it so if
you rented it out you'd probably just I
mean I don't know how much rent you get
for that what you reckon you'd get if
you rent it out yeah it weighs quite a
decent it's like it it's detached as now
yeah I mean potentially one of the
things that I could because because
because I've been I've been in the game
now I mean I'm young I'm a my like I'm
20 I'm 29 but I've been I bought my
first house at 18 and I've been doing
this I've been in this industry for you
know for 11 years I mean one of the
things that sometimes I've done on
several occasions and people in your
situation that wanted to get get get
wash the hands of a property but they've
got no equity in it at all is I could
potentially take over your mortgage and
become the landlord and but and
basically pay you the 450 or whatever it
is a month and and I'd become a landlord
you'd be able to walk away from the
property and they're not officially
complete on it down the line at 120 but
that will be quite quick way of
relieving it from yeah I'm
I don't know if anyone's proposed
anything on that G before well what I do
what I do in that situation is there's
two things you can do the first thing is
you can give to what you can you can
give 12 months notice so if it was over
five years say after four years you'd
have to say this is my intention and
then at that point you can't you can't
you cannot walk away legally you have to
buy it another thing you could do is you
could set up something in place where
you have to pay a fee so if you walk
away you have to pay a few thousand
pounds face and it's a little bit of
incentive there so that I mean there's a
few options I mean I'll be very happy to
send you an email over and also include
my yeah have a look at it and also if
you wanted to talk about the legal side
of it you know chat to us Lister about
it because I've done it quite
successfully with people that have got
no that could say in your situation so I
mean at least it's at least the options
there for you so you've not you've not
got the headache if I thing to worry
about the house anymore
you want me to send you an email over
just giving you a bit of an outliner
yeah all right then listen I'll drop you
an email over shortly and then hey if
you want to have a chat further just
just drop me a message back all right
hey you have a great day I'll speak to
you soon
that's the thing when you try and get
below market value offers in order to
then sell a deal what happens is
sometimes people say I can't do that
because I've got a mortgage that could
be my lease option agreement right there
because I mean if he's paying for 50 a
month looking at that house I mean that
house I reckon would right now easily I
think for about 650 I mean look how nice
that look and nice that is it's a
beautiful house so if I'm only making
150 quid a month it's not amazing but
I've got the capital appreciation on it
so he understood it he'd been offered it
before let's see if I can get get go
ahead and get the deal
and now I've got some lease option
agreement leads in the back
sometimes I've also had my investor
friends my 91 investors which is now
I bet it's gone up let's see what it now
is oh my goodness it's now a hundred and
one I need to keep resending an email I
need to also make this soon so I've had
a lot of them email me back why is it
going to begin no it's hundred oh I've
had a lot of them email me back saying
what kind of properties are looking for
so solo ideally a four or five bed HMO
in Liverpool interesting says David
everyone's called David look all these
messages back I'm looking for a BRR
house two to three beds for single that
in Birmingham area I'm not looking for
net cash flow see what else I got
I'm looking for a HMO my limit is 120 so
maybe I should be looking for HMOs in
Liverpool a rental renting Leste will be
awesome may see all of these people
where they come from
anything in stoke-on-trent or
surrounding area BRR and good property
holding for the long term
discounted single lets in t side mm-hmm
just to describe I do extensive due
diligence on each deal proposed which
meant I reject 99% of all deals sent to
me by property sources but sometimes
people do send me the deals that make
sense and I buy those marcin fair play
he'd buy from me he'd buy from me what
else you got being v deals so so people
are responding telling me what they're
looking for so I think Liverpool HMOs be
envies in stoke-on-trent interest in
times interest in times all right let's
keep going
I reckon I'm gonna get that lease option
agreement I really have a good feeling
about that lease option agreement I'm
gonna send him an email right now okay
okay so it's been a fantastic couple of
days so basically I've got a potential
lease option agreement I've got a
potential below market value deal that I
can sell I've got a few of the leads in
the bag I've sent out a few messages to
some auction people some because there's
a lot of properties that aren't selling
in auction so I'm in our messaging
auctioneers
and I'm saying hey any of your
property's not sold if so can I have a
chat so I'm just pumping out loads of
messages now on spare room open rent
whatsapp Gumtree my investor list is
building like crazy I've now got one
hundred and thirty six investors that
are already looking to buy I'm just
trying to get some actual really good
tangible tangible deals gonna be
negotiating going to be putting in
another video up soon guys I want to see
what you're doing as well this is not
just you watch me this is you do it with
me so I've put on now two videos I'm
gonna be putting out a third video next
week abso-freakin'-lutely I want to see
what you do it I want to see what's
happening so subscribe stay tuned smash
the like button drop a comment below let
me know what you want me to see doing
next
more or less whatever you want to see
let me know but most importantly I want
to see you so comment share videos and
use the hashtag lock down property
challenge let's do this baby
let's do this